[Musique]
mais alors pourquoi continue à aller
voir le psychanalyste
ce que l'on demande aujourd'hui au
psychanalyste ça n'a c'est très
différent de ce que venait demander le
névrosé
je parle déjà jeunes qui viennent quand
ils viennent et ils viennent chez le
psychanalyste
ce qui vient de demander c'est pas que
la cure leur permet l'expression
d'un désir refoulé
mais c'est que la cure leur permet de
savoir
quel serait l'heure désir
renversement un renversement absolu
et la cure peut-elle le permet c'est la
question
ouverte avec avec chacun d'entre eux
ils veulent savoir
ce que serait l'heure désir propre
non pas seulement leur participation à
des activités
diverses collectives etc
lui en tant que tel en tant que vivant
mais qu'est-ce que
est autour de quoi viendrait-il gravité
la violence et généralement surgit quand
la parole de l'un n'est plus reconnue
par l'autre et aujourd'hui elle surgit à
tout propos car le sujet ne se sent
jamais reconnu comme sujet
la violence est toujours rétorcive chez
un sujet c'est toujours une réponse et
réponse à quoi à une autre violence donc
on a affaire un violent il faut d'abord
lui demander de quelle violence il a été
lui-même victime
quelle est la pire des violences que
sujet capable de subir c'est la violence
la plus fréquente la plus douce la plus
soft la plus invisible la plus
inapparente et qui est celle qui vous
méconnais dans votre existence de sujet
c'est à dire celle qui vous inclut dans
un dialogue dans un propos dans une
situation dans la méconnaissance et dans
le refus d'avoir à reconnaître ce que
vous pouvez en penser en réalité on
éprouvait en réalité voir à dire
là-dessus
cette méconnaissance du sujet c'est la
situation la plus traumatisante et la
plus violente qui puisse y avoir et
aujourd'hui
particulièrement fréquente bien entendu
dans toutes les formes de relation
sociale où l'on attend je dirais des
travailleurs des collaborateurs etc
qu'il participe à leur tâche
engagement subjectif je veux dire leur
demande pas ce qu'ils peuvent ce que ça
peut leur faire
c'est la grande cause
de toutes les violences et celles des
enfants dans les écoles ou dans les
quartiers
réputés malfamé etc n'a pas d'autres
d'autres origines n'a pas d'autre cause
de même la violence conjugale bien sûr
c'est que
c'est que le conjoint
s'en fiche
si je sens l'existence
par sa présence ni de ce qui est attendu
de lui mais
on se fiche du fait que il existe alors
il arrive il arrive bien sûr que
certains aiment ça c'est
traité comme des objets
bien sûr
mais ça c'est un aspect je dirais
particulier de la question
dans le grand fonctionnement
je dirais
technologiquement
engagée qui est qui est le nôtre
dans cette agencement
le sujet n'a aucune place il est fort
clos
alors être fort clos c'est la condition
du sujet moderne
et c'est celui que aussi bien qu'un
appel le sujet de l'inconscient et le
sujet qui n'a pas sa place dans le champ
de la réalité sociale
alors il lui reste plus qu'à se faire
entendre par des espèces de petits
couacs qui sont les symptômes les lapsus
les actes manqués
un certain nombre de conneries etc
des désirs qui
ne sauraient aboutir
un sujet il commence à devenir violent à
partir du moment où ce qu'il dit n'est
pas entendu ou être investi ou aimé
connu ou est transformé ou ignoré c'est
à dire ou en tant que sujet il est
annulé
et quel autre moyen pour témoigner son
existence à ce moment-là si ce n'est de
manifester par quelques expressions
physiques que l'on est bien là
et de le faire savoir à l'autre
aujourd'hui
on a plus besoin d'individus que de
sujets sujet c'est toujours embarrassant
c'est compliqué c'est ennuyeux c'est pas
ce qu'il veut dire
c'est parce qu'il veut il ne sait pas
lui-même
il est jamais content etc et
les expressions de la vie
sont bien celles de ce sujet
[Musique]